Nick Cannon AKA dressy Jackson AKA Mr
Pop a lot AKA yo Daddy's daddy we
getting it in uh this is the bootleg Kev
podcast let's go it's incredible
Kev show uh big special guest in here
big inspiration of mine one of the
hardest working guys in entertainment uh
he also has quite possibly the most
impressive hit list of all time here you
go Nick
I Hit It First Canyon uh what's good man
I'll take the intro I'll take it what's
up beloved you good yeah I told you this
because you had we had to call on the
show I was like I'm just glad you ain't
at Power 106 anymore because now we can
have you on the show I know man but
that's it I was talking to Big about
that it was always love it was always
love but you know like that's old
mentality like first of all everybody
owns all of their content now everybody
likes so the people who move like
dinosaurs I'm like this is our gang and
that's your game I agree with you we
gotta like that we gotta let that [__]
go listen I totally agree with you the
problem is is that there are people who
are
but that's what I'm saying we can't be
maneuvering like well-paid servants you
know what I mean like no there's like my
thing is like damn like I [__] with like
so many people at power 106. but that
was like first of all I never like I
didn't work for power 106. I was
partners with them so I heard did they
give you a restaurant or something like
that a little SLS dealer saying let's
make some money here
and some SLS but that's what I'm saying
like we got to stop thinking like
especially I encourage anybody who wants
to get a new space of media or
entertainment uh specifically podcasting
already own your [__] because when you
do that then if if your boy got a
podcast I got a pocket then we can get
money together but this mentality of
like this is my station that's your
station that's when you don't own the
radio stations yeah like that's always
like you gang banging on blocks your own
yeah for sure it's like you could wake
up tomorrow and the company can be like
we're flipping yeah and then you got to
go get a job over at the places doesn't
you're right yeah so but that's why I
was always loved like it was never like
but I mean like you said the powers that
be some of them get still stuck in that
old school mentality of like the
competition is how we you know come on
man we all can get numbers we all can do
our thing what is something you learned
from because you've done radio a lot I
don't think people understand you are
moving to New York good
um you you still have the syndicated
show with always my my syndicated show
my syndicated countdown uh I've been
doing that for over a decade right
you've been doing that for a long time
but then like you know what did what did
you learn from the Power 106 experience
because it it obviously there was there
was Downs yeah I think I think again
like I always say like you got to move
like a boss at the end of the day and
even more so like a leader I mean like I
I we know what that brand means to our
community to hip-hop and stuff so the
legendary radio station so that was the
whole purpose for me even being over
there wanting to be like look this I was
I had a daily talk show at the same time
uh I had you know Mass singer wilding
out so it was another outlet for that I
felt like was a a real uh
probably like fixture in the community
that I could really harness and even
that time there was times where I was
you know they asked me if I wanted to
buy the station now the once once we
looked into it there's no point in like
you know it's probably overpriced yeah
you don't need to pay for dinosaurs you
know what I mean when you can go uh
create something of your own uh and
invest the same amount of money and you
own it 100 uh and you don't have to
worry about you know satellite Towers so
they offered you to buy it yeah oh wow
what did you could tell us how much it
was I mean it was 50 40. no no not that
much oh really it was less yeah yeah 20.
yeah so I'm wearing that around that
around that area so um but to say all of
that it's like you know even the things
like I've been able to you know I'm
probably one of the few people in
entertainment that I was able to have
deals that you know uh NBC and Universal
and fox and uh Viacom and all those
places at the same time it is kind of
crazy yeah I'm on every Network yeah so
give me your okay so when you're doing
mornings and you have the TV show and
you have math singer and you have wild
and out yeah and you have don't forget
my new number one show celebrity Prank
Wars of Kevin Hart number one
and you have
the biggest family family known to man
uh me NBA young boy yeah he just had
number 11. he had number 11. he
he could catch me because he started
earlier than me I had no kids I was 30.
so what do you do in terms of like just
scheduling making sure you don't go
crazy making sure you have time for the
kids making sure you have time for
yourself yeah I can't even imagine I'll
tell everybody's like energy management
man if you see me I'm cool calm and
collected I know how to manage my my
energy probably better than most I'm not
I don't move off of emotion or other
people's energy uh because people think
it's time management but time is a you
know a man-made construct that we all
subscribe to like you can get enough of
that you can get but it's having the
right team and knowing how to delegate
your energy because you I've been in
situations where I've overly stressed
myself I've been in situations where
there was literally too much on my plate
and people were just constantly pulling
at me but when you know how to manage
your energy
um I think that that allows you to do
more than the average human being so
it's about the key would be delegation a
little bit of it I mean how to delegate
them because we got some people who
delegate in a way that like it is
stressful and it's toxic right but like
you just gotta allow people you know
people strengths you know people's
weaknesses you know the ability to say
all right I have this much to give then
I gotta go recharge right and also so
much of like everything you do you're
you're you have to be there yeah yeah
it's not like you're doing stuff you can
do from the crib or you can like do on a
laptop no you have to literally be in
front of a camera yeah but like somebody
asked me or tell me like man you don't
have no free time I was like all my time
is free time it's perspective it's how
you look at it everything I do I love it
so my vocation is my vacation so it's a
situation where like I would a lot of
stuff I'd get paid to do I would pay to
do you know what I'm saying and and I
think that's that's really the nature of
what I talk about managing your
bandwidth your spiritual bandwidth and
your energy because from that standpoint
we make time for the things we want
right and and you know as a father you
got to make that a number one priority
but then everything else is really just
a big ass hobby
um
while and out is it season 20 yeah we're
coming up on 20 right now it's crazy
because I do feel like when we think of
like the most successful TV shows ever I
think that like Wild n Out has surpassed
so many of the shows that we look back
on and be like this like I I think
sometimes it's almost like when LeBron's
playing we don't realize we're watching
LeBron yeah yeah and I feel like one day
when wild now it's over they're gonna
appreciate it we're gonna be like damn
wild and out was on for x amount of
years and was heat and there was all
these moments with all these [__]
legendary artists yeah just so many just
memorable and the fact that it was dope
about it because you bring up a good
point of like what the definition of
what a TV show is we know because that's
our generation the kids today don't even
understand it to be a TV show they
understand it's like of Tick Tock
YouTube viral sensation kids kids used
to come up to me like oh man I love your
show uh you make it's my favorite show
now kids come up to me like man I love
your videos yeah I love I love you know
like they I love the content like they
let really say that so it's like nobody
watches the big [__] on the wall anymore
it's like it's in their hands on the
iPads and we're probably more successful
online than we've ever been than we were
on television well the show's like very
great for today's like environment yeah
it is Eclipse yep them small we know how
to compartmentalize and break up those
clips for you know all day long and so
one of the most I think we're probably
the the uh the biggest uh digital
imprint in uh the whole entire Paramount
Network that includes Comedy Central
that includes
yeah it's wilding out and we have more
followers on YouTube more followers on
Tick Tock uh than anything else in in
the Paramount ecosystem so maybe The
Daily Show might be like close on one of
those can you give me um some insight on
like the beginning of wild and out like
the break like like this is your baby
this is your your you know your idea
like yeah man I was just really trying
to [__] give my friends jobs like I
did like people didn't know who Kevin
Hart and Affion Crockett DeRay Davis
yeah you made it you made a lot of these
guys man they didn't know and I don't
mean you
make
yeah yeah absolutely
um and because actually they were all my
my colleagues and counterparts they were
they were because you came up you were
doing a little stand up at a certain
point in time because you started in San
Diego doing stand-ups yeah I started
doing stand I mean I started yeah I
started in that I started in music
obviously when I was even younger but
stand up is what put me on the mat got
me my first deal at uh Jamie Foxx's uh
Lollapalooza uh in Atlanta and then from
there by the way prayers with Jamie Foxx
yeah always I I'm believing in a hundred
percent complete healing that's my
brother right there we've been praying
strong for I might need security one of
the best specials ever yeah and first of
all he's the most talented man on the
planet 100 yeah I say it's either him or
Chris Brown those are the one and two
those are the two those are the one and
two and all the videos because Chris
hasn't been able to spread his wings the
way fox has in it well I look at Chris
as like Chris is really good at
basketball yeah and he can paint a mural
yeah yeah
and both of them like the nicest human
beings in the world so it's like it's
it's you want to go to either party at
either one of those dudes house so for a
while now you kind of come from the
stand-up background these are your
friends these are guys who you consider
your peers and for you it was like what
there's not an outlet well I was doing
movies and music and stuff at the time
so yeah love don't cost a thing was
already on you are you were popping yeah
and those cats was looking at me like yo
man spread the love so I was like all
right I'm gonna go to MTV because I was
I was hosting TRL doing all that stuff
so I went to them and they didn't
understand it at first they was like you
want to do what right and I was like nah
we got this comedy club and we do this
this thing is like they didn't really
understand it so I was like all right
[__] it I'll rent The Comedy Club on
myself got some cameras together uh
called everybody to the club and we shot
that [__] and therefore I own the IP
since the day one so you bankrolled the
demo yep shot the demo yourself that and
then shopped it around and they said
then now I had now I had all the equity
and and the negotiating power because
how so for people who don't know I think
a lot of people are a little bit more
familiar with like record deals yeah
yeah so if you're trying to get a TV
show Deal usually a production company
comes in with the money to pay for the
pilot and that's their excuse to take
ownership exactly but if you handle that
yourself then you come to the table I
already got this handled yeah you want
it or not yeah and then that everything
from the the Wild and out logo to all
those it was all owned by me
was it a scary situation where they
tried getting you up out of here and it
felt like they took you off TV it was
like it was they try to cancel me like
at least once a year well I mean no I
know but there was there was the time I
think uh it was a couple years ago and
you had the interview I forget I don't
want to get into it yeah but that's I
mean that was a learning moment that you
went through with everybody 100 you know
what I mean but that's the thing like
moments like that uh either show your
toughness and show how quickly you could
fold so you know uh I think Martin
Luther King said it best it was like the
test of the true test of a man's
character isn't in times of comfort but
in times of controversy so that that
just shows you how solid I was to every
Community to where where most people
instantly or they they waver and we're
like I leaned into it and then we began
to to understand and really focus not
only on my business and saw who was
riding with me and who wasn't but then
at the same time uh any wrongdoings that
I I made I corrected as every man should
and I think we need to be more more uh I
mean it's kind of crazy because we don't
give a lot of people that opportunity
anymore yeah and I mean I got another
show that I'm creating uh right now that
I already created that we already shot
that'll be debuting pretty soon but
literally does what deals with that I
mean I coined the Frank Council culture
it's not about cancel culture it's
countable so don't cancel one another
Council one and that [__] to take your
brother and show them how to shake it up
and how to really get it right and give
them an opportunity none of us are
greater than God and so we should allow
him to be the one to judge yeah I feel
like in a time where like we're so at
least perceived I think we have a lot
more in common than people would like to
talk about yeah they always say there's
more uh there's similarities and
differences small things that people are
far apart on but everything else they
they everyone loves their family
everyone wants to be safe everyone wants
to be Prosper but if you don't agree on
this or this it's like you gotta hate
the other person and I think yeah and
that's I mean a Buddhist mentality is we
are one without uh one without none and
none without one so in that idea of like
we got we need each other to to operate
and if we keep allowing the powers that
be to split us up it really feels like
it is some powers that be [__] bro yeah
like because that's how they control you
they control you divide and conquer
that's right but if we really understand
like again like we got more similarities
and differences in in the [__] that we
bicker about is I mean that's one of the
things that I say while and I was the
most Progressive show on television
because we can have people from two
different walks of life we can have
someone from the Jewish Community some
from the Muslim Community and they go at
it and hug it out at the end we can have
a homophobic person and a transgender
person go at it and hug it out at the
end because but they talk the most [__]
say the most stereotypical offensive
stuff but when you say it's up all the
gods of family and comedy and humor we
we win so but when you allow that stuff
to be rooted in hate and therefore you
think you better than somebody else
because of your life experience for sure
vice versa that's where [__] goes wrong
yeah I think it's like people will talk
out of like people will make mistakes
and I think that's just human nature
yeah so if someone makes a mistake
that's not from a hateful place exactly
correct talk to them yeah that's why
they put a races on pencils it's like
yeah it's like yo I don't [__] with
Earthlings
so the new show that you you're working
on is called it's called Council culture
yeah you know you're getting the
exclusive here because I actually it
wasn't supposed to talk about that yet
uh but yeah that's it's something I I
kind of realized man that uh when I was
doing my daytime talk show I was like
this ain't where the bag is you know
what I mean all of that Ellen money and
Oprah money they came and scooped all of
that up yeah it's kind of like they kind
of got the last of that yeah yeah so I
went in there I was like there's no way
this makes sense to make it takes 16
hours to make one hour and the bandwidth
of doing it every day like it was trying
to do radio like it was literally
draining me so I had to step away so I
was like I want to be able to do the
same thing have the same type of impact
but you know Consolidated into 12
episodes of the Season or something yeah
but really what what even even on a
daily perspective it's like it has to be
able to be a part of my lifestyle
opposed to me trying to come here and
show it for work like I don't work for
nobody so like when if it feels like I
got a job then I'm I'm out but uh the
fact that I can actually live my life
and document the process and show the
process and actually truly help people
and you know the fact that I go to
therapy a few times a week how can I
bring that to the table the fact that
you know I have great relationships with
the mothers and my children and knowing
how fascinated and intrigued people are
by my life how can I offer that in a way
to not only I can be open and honest and
control my own narrative but then at the
same time you know monetize it for you
um talk about like
you are listen
12 children yes 12 kids
um obviously your friends and Counting
some may say and Counting nah I think
I'm I'm good with my dirty does it right
now let me ask you something
do you ever regret not getting Kim
Kardashian pregnant
how you try to go viral I'm just asking
I'm just asking because I look back at
your history and I'm like man if there
was ever anyone that you could have put
one up a bun in the oven it could have
been the billionaire uh you know what
I'll believe that one alone
I'm tired of going viral every week they
already got mad at me about what I said
about Taylor Swift oh you didn't say you
Christina Milian so I know that's now he
says he's gonna get Kim Kardashian he
regrets because how would work how old
was Kim when you dated her oh we were
both like in our mid-20s was this post
love don't cost a thing or preach just
right after love don't go sit there such
a classic [__] yeah just like a great
movie nah man it's fun we're back I mean
I stepped away from from uh I kind of
make like one movie a year that I own
and control but I think I'm gonna dive
back into movies in a little bit like
probably in the next five years and and
kind of get back to that space of like
making classic content for our community
have you thought about like their like
the lack of good comedies anything it's
crazy like done I think cancel culture
yeah yeah or just over sensitizing just
we lost all our our R-rated comedies
that made it good comedy yeah this trip
was great yeah there's like 10 since
some hangover yeah girls trip and
bridesmaids are the only two that yeah
yeah and those are I don't I don't well
that was I guess those were those
R-rated guys yeah but like it's been 12
years since we've gotten like a classic
hardcore comedy yeah no yeah I'm even in
the sense of like you said too just
stuff that even that you know you can
sit around and watch with the family too
like we don't have none of those like
family films we don't have yeah like
we're our forest gumps where you know
like where's the stuff like that
everything's like Marvel or yeah like
Billy Madison or the water boy like that
[__] used I remember Waterboy opened the
80 million dollars this first week you
know I mean like yeah no it's kind of
crazy because I always think like I'm
like someone Rich enough hello uh needs
to come along and just be like [__] it
you gotta focus on it though that's the
thing that to make a good movie you
gotta focus on that [__] like one it
takes the money uh but then it also you
gotta make sure your marketing is is
together on the post and even like you
can't make a good movie without having a
great script so it's like it's stuff
like that that you just it it it's like
I've done independent films really well
too but then because you can make the
greatest independent film in the world
but if they don't reach the amount of
people then nobody ever really really
know except for the festivals that gave
you you know your little Laurels and
crests so if you to do a great classic
film you got to check the boxes from
development all the way to it's actually
in the theaters so it take it takes it
takes trust me people ask me all the
time and you should do more movies it's
like that's the most uh time consuming
[__] out there I bet it's to make a good
movie a good movie you could put you
could put some Hood classic Tubi [__]
out yeah shout out to me I [__] with
them heavy but like he's running it up
yeah but but if you if you want to make
some classic [__] if you want to make
Menace to Society boys in the hood uh
Drumline love don't cost a thing I mean
like I think you know probably for the
culture they did it the right way uh I
love it with Mike B is doing from you
know I feel like Cree to go down
Classics I feel like black panther go
down as Classics but anything else for
the culture ain't resonated except for
like those those Jordans I mean
obviously Jordan peels putting out some
crazy yeah but would you horror movie
yeah would that is that are we are we
gonna be talking about though I'm just a
question like I think I think get out
absolutely get out for sure get out I'm
not sure us or uh what's the last one
the other one [__] it just came out yeah
see that I mean yes like but no offense
but I'm like because you only can and
what time will tell as well you know
what I mean like like people people
didn't really start [__] with Love
Don't Cost a Thing heavy until back then
it was out on home video right I mean
they did decent in the in the theaters
but then once it was constantly playing
that your auntie and your mama's house
all the time then it became a classic so
you know maybe these films that we're
talking about today but I'm saying the
ones that feel like you know what we
talk about we talk about Love Jones we
talk about do the right thing talk about
the wood boys in the hood there's none
of that [__] yeah
all right people try but they come short
every time I've come short you know been
like damn you know why because the
studio didn't like I made a film called
that everybody it's a hood classic like
school dance but everybody was talking
is that the one James is in James
Jefferson yeah yeah but everybody was
talking like when we was making it they
was like oh this is like the next Friday
because Davidson's in it yeah Pete
Davidson and Tiffany haddish Kat
Williams George Lopez Mike Epps Kevin
Hart little Duvall like Brunell we had
everybody in this [__] and it's
hilarious if you watch it but because
Lionsgate didn't Market it correctly and
they did they did they didn't really
know what they had they just threw that
[__] out there so it's like you got it
when I say from the script to the time
like it's [__] in the theaters and
like the marketing all that everything
got to be pristine would you ever try to
develop like a scripted like drama or
comedy or something like we got some
[__] we got some [__] coming like I
gotta I got a pretty uh like I said I
got deals at all of these different
because instead of like I do feel like
we we don't get it in movies anymore but
we do get it in shows yeah we do it and
that's so false fire there's some great
comedy shows yeah so I got uh we've been
developing for a while and I just you
know I I like making more moves and less
announcements but I can I can tell you
about the [__] that we've been cooking
up and spending money on is uh uh me E40
and Too Short uh got the yay area
project is that the one Simba's in uh no
no not that one that one's fire like
that one was playing too short and yeah
yeah I heard about no I'm talking about
this is like a series that the three of
us are producing that's gonna be like
the same way that you see the bmfs the
the powers the the wives are you just
trying to put it together and then shop
ah some things I can't talk about right
now but I heard 50 cents leaving Stars
they could use you
hey that's good business over there but
I mean like I do have a few deals set up
around town that allow me to do scripted
things so we excited about it I do feel
like what I appreciated about your
YouTube show it was Canon's class right
yeah yeah yeah I feel feel like you were
doing like a lot of dope like necessary
interviews uh conversations and they've
kind of gone away well yeah see we
launched accountants class again I
actually kind of never went away but now
even on a bigger level again because now
I was doing that before podcasting was
the thing to do and it was really part
of my college curriculum at Howard
University now I just love the the
YouTube channel like yeah I remember
when you went back I can big you on yeah
yeah you had some dope episodes we back
on that too we we definitely and you'll
start seeing uh that stuff roll back out
it was just I had to get I had to get
everything aligned because I do have so
many shows that I wanted people to
recognize and respect where the content
was coming from okay
your schedule on December 25th every
year
what are we doing I'm saying Nick baby
are we bringing everyone to the same
crib I think I always I was saying is I
think that only benefits me you know
what I mean because then everybody has
to come to me I think that's pretty
selfish 12 kids you got 24 hours in a
day on Christmas yeah just the half
Latino ones get Christmas Eve because
that's their day well you know what
they're to your point you're joking
that's the truth because Abby and her
kids they celebrate Christmas on on the
24th you see you know how this works
like some tamales yeah exactly no uh to
be honest though it is really about I
mean I just it just happened even again
with Easter it's like you know you don't
you don't necessarily have to operate
based off of the the social construct
that everybody else is subscribed to so
we make sure that we we celebrate
Christmas however long we want to
celebrate Christmas so it could be the
27th I mean not that late but I mean
like it's a it's enough it could be the
22nd yeah you know they always wonder
how Santa Claus can deliver all those
presents and still get home to Mrs Claus
by the morning so it's a we move around
and I'm I'm festive like that as much as
holidays the pagan holidays don't matter
to me I love what it does for children
so I'm always dressing up and Chris it
ain't Christmas day it's Christmas week
you know I'm in my house it's a week
yeah it has to be a week yeah like we
throwing Easter egg hunts all week long
when it's Easter time I mean all the
moms and kids live in Cali besides
Mariah she lives in Cali too okay yeah I
mean she's obviously you know she got
property every special singer ever yeah
but that's usually it is you know we we
got we got houses on the east coast and
the West Coast so we everybody's the
newer children are all in Cali uh
currently yeah yeah I told you I got
Calabasas on a lot you just yeah
it's Canon basses everyone's over there
everybody's over there that Ralph's got
it yeah mom's got to be running into
each other Ralph's and [__] we lit we
turn we tear the commons up what up
y'all we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our folks at my bookie
look baseball season it is back in full
swing and my bookie your One Stop Shop
for everything you need to get money off
of your favorite baseball teams your
favorite baseball players all the
betting knees they got you man so many
different options including money lines
the Run lines totals Futures all of it
my bookie gives you plenty of ways to
bet on your favorite teams and players
and get some of that money you can also
take advantage of the brand new mybookie
money bag it gives you the chance to
secure a bet on your favorite team or
player at crazy boosted odds what you
got to do right now sign up in my bookie
use the promo code bootleg to secure a
first deposit bonus up to a thousand
dollars now how that works is if you
deposit two hundred dollars
you get to play with 300 instantly
that's what we're doing all right all
you got to do is use that promo code
bootleg to claim your bonus ASAP so look
if you're a baseball fan there's so much
excitement when it comes to betting
baseball you know I would say baseball
is one of the funnest and easiest
Sports to gamble on if you really know
what the [__] you're doing uh plus we
got the NBA Playoffs coming
so much happening with the playoffs we
got the play-in tournament we got the uh
let's see
I love the series the Cavaliers versus
Nets Knicks because the Nets are not
playing the Cavaliers the Knicks are
wrong New York team Suns vs Clippers
[__] Hammer the Suns
minus 200 to beat the Clippers it's
gonna happen all right so look go to my
bookie right now sign up with that promo
code bootleg and get that first deposit
bonus ladies and gentlemen it's so easy
I promise you my book has got it covered
for you baseball uh of course basketball
NBA playoffs Futures you go I mean they
got the casino popping they got
Blackjack they got roulette they got it
all
mybookie.ag promo code bootleg Kev promo
code bootleg actually go sign up you'll
see it it's right there
and we got to give a big shout out to
the good folks of blue chew that's right
ladies and gentlemen it's getting a
little hot outside that's right it's
getting super hot it is getting hot
finally tired of this [__] cold ass
weather you know what that means it's
[__] season baby that's right if you
are you know maybe dealing with a little
erectile dysfunction
it happens to the best of us you don't
have to be an old guy to get Ed you
might just have a we don't even say what
you might have but maybe you're dealing
with stress at work maybe you're dealing
with stress at home and you're not
performing up to par maybe your penis
could be a little bit more harder let's
be honest that's really what we're
talking about here right go to
bluetooth.com right now and use the
promo code bootleg and you can get a
month's supply for free that's right a
month supply for free at bluetooth.com
now a lot of people are asking what is
Bluetooth how does it work does it work
one of course it works two how does it
work it has the same active ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis but it's in a blue
chewable tablet yes it's a chewable all
right and the best part about it you
don't even have to go to the doctor's
office to get it it's all online you
don't have to have any sort of embarrass
embarrassing conversations with people
in regards to you know your junk not
working the way you want to to work or
whatever the [__] all you got to do is
go online to bluetooth.com
they're going to get you situated with
your first month for free as long as you
use that promo code bootleg free month
supply of Bluetooth use the promo code
bootleg it gets delivered straight to
your door discrete packaging plus they
got the new mint flavor which is the
same exact active ingredient is Levitra
so many ways you can Bluetooth man I'll
tell you this though it's about to get
hot as [__] outside you're about to hit
that spring break you want to make sure
you're equipped you know what I mean
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg get a
free month on me all you do is pay five
dollars in shipping what's up y'all
bootleg Kev here got to tell you about
our homies uh who are our new sponsor at
the podcast and it's so dope that we got
to work with them because I've been
using their product for so long I'm
talking about the homies at King Palm
baby that's right shout out to King Palm
if y'all don't know all natural
tobacco-free no additive Leaf wraps all
right they're literal Leafs all right
and when I tell you they're the best uh
they're the industry leader when it
comes to the tobacco-free Natural Leaf
wrap situation and my [__] is this they
got these uh amazing wraps that come
with these
flavor infused terpene tips and these
ones right here
the red rains are a movie shout out to
the red Reigns because the dope thing
about these is they taste like a goddamn
energy drink when you squeeze the tip
all right there's so much you can get
when it comes to King Palm so many dough
products of course their stable product
is that empty Leaf tube with the
pre-installed filter tip no need to lick
or roll it all you do is just pack it
with what you want some of them legal
herbs and get it in all right and check
this out right now you can go to the
website kingpom.com use the promo code
bootleg Kev for 50 off so much we're
talking about rollable wraps hemp cones
and all the essential smoking
accessories you will ever need for the
smoothest smoke easy to use go order
them right now kingpom.com with that
promo code bootleg calf or go to your
local smoke shop even that 7-Eleven
that's on the Block they're gonna have
the King Palm they are the pioneer of
the natural Leaf wrap and they're
getting you hooked up right now at
kingpom.com promo code bootleg Kev half
off all right shout out to King pong the
Watermelons are fire too I'm gonna go
with the watermelon and the energy drink
the red rain gas or you can just go with
just the normal boys
you know what I mean
man who would like to smoke just
straight natural organic Don't Panic
it's organic man free of tobacco and
additives go [__] with King Palm using
that promo code bootleg kept at
kingpom.com let's get back to the
interview dude are are your kids moms
friends at all uh what I never like to
generalize because or they or are they
at least cordial friends like they don't
like the ones who it's like they I I'll
leave that up to them in the narratives
in which they share every no like
everybody is
like nurturing and loving it and
respectful enough that they they
understand what's going on so nobody got
any problems or any negativity like we
fly on a higher frequency than that so
like but I ain't you know don't expect
everybody to be hanging out together but
it's like listen I'm just trying to
figure because I've seen a lot of these
Cults or cold Netflix documentaries
recently the Canon cult is the Canon
Cults a thing you must wear a turbanon
you must have at least one base to
operate against the circadian clock
um nah man I think it's just I mean
obviously I'm probably just more open
and honest about myself you are very
very transparent about it I think look
at look at you know everybody from the
Bob Marley's to the Muhammad Ali's to
the you know Quincy Joneses of the world
these all of these great men have are
fathers of many and right but I do think
what you did was you did it all at once
hey man the clock is ticking it felt
like it was so crazy because like we do
a national syndicated radio show every
day and
I couldn't talk about you on the show
because our biggest affiliate was a real
92.3 yeah Power 106. and I do they
literally tell you don't talk about it I
just you know just shout out to Doc I
ain't [__] with doctors of course he
is but we were our kids was playing
together when we was competition so
um it would be crazy because me and
James would be like [__] Nick's having a
[__] we can't talk about it felt like
every six weeks there was just a new I
think it's it's it's you know because
all the kids are going to be pretty soon
so this is going to be an interesting
upbringing I mean I'm pretty sure there
will be some challenge but I think
there'll be some beautiful things
graduation put them all in the same
school I'm hoping I mean in the same
area it all depends you know what I mean
but you know even some of my kids right
now are homeschooled so it's like we'll
we'll figure all of that stuff what will
school be in 10 years if you want to be
honest with it you know based off of the
way the world is going so I I think you
know a lot of my kids right now are
active in extracurricular activities and
sports and stuff so that probably might
become challenging to where you know
they're definitely trying to make a
certain similar games on certain days
you know baseball basketball on track
overlap you know what I mean so even
sometimes they can't even make it to
their own games so it's like it's always
going to be something you've only been
married once so what's tomorrow yeah
yeah and only will be married once it's
only going to happen so when all this
starts first happening right yeah does
Mariah call you be like what the [__]
are you doing bruh not really we have
that type of like type of conversation
but she's a little bit more
understanding she's going to be like I
see you out there Making Waves like she
kind of comes from it more from that
perspective but that there was no I
think only sometimes maybe when things
in the media get misconstrued or people
make up stuff like you got to clear it
up yeah we talk every day so I'm like yo
like it was some wow [__] of like saying
that we were having like a custody
battle or something I saw that yeah and
it's like I was like we just was at
dinner yesterday you ain't tell me you
know but it's like once we kind of do
away with our all the rumors because
people do like to start rumors and
operate in that low frequency but we are
we all be on the same phase do you still
have the tattoo would you cover it up I
added to it shall we say cat
it's my whole that was my only tattoo at
one time now I remember I remember yeah
I was like this this guy's outside yeah
yeah yeah he got the home it was Mariah
Carey damn bro I can't buy or nothing
that she can't buy it Ryan Carey was my
as a small child she was like my first
crush yeah so when I saw I was like
shout out to Nick man it was Brian JLo
yeah and actually my boy ended up being
with JLo Casper Smart see look at his
young tycoons out here in these streets
getting it together man
um how well I want to talk about because
I don't feel like you get enough credit
in terms of your ear for Talent on the
music side uh a girl like kailani
somebody who was signed with you
initially her was signed when she was
11. yeah to you to incredible yeah
um you have like a now she went in
Oscars Grammys and stuff shout out to
Young Gabby out there yeah how like for
you like
why do you think you'll get enough
credit man when it comes to the music
[__] because I feel like I think I feel
like people obviously think listen
you've put out some dope records but I
also feel like people don't really take
you serious as an as an artist never
tried to push it well also because I
feel like we just see you as doing so
many other things and like I came up in
a time where you couldn't do more than
one thing right so I had to pick and
choose so I chose you know you know
comedy and yeah Gigolo movies and [__]
but so you couldn't do both when I was
young right but what's dope is that I I
was a DJ and a producer like all through
high school so I didn't really I never
wanted to be in front of the camera so
throughout my career I've written and
produced records that there I got
platinum records all day long but it's
just like I never was like this is me
looking and paying attention to me even
when it came to the Artistry stuff I
never was really on that so what I've
done now just because obviously the
spotlight is hot I I created a new show
for BT uh called future Superstars and
it's a tour as well so so you just were
on tour with uh Simba 24K so yeah so the
fact that now the television show will
show that Journey they would show you
know me as a music man and show me in
the space of talent Discovery or show me
me as a producer and all of that type of
stuff so I'm excited about that that
wave of my career because I had it has I
I haven't talked about it it has been
the afterthought a lot of times even
though I've been doing you know I make
all the music on wild and out you know
what I mean like I I it's a I'm a
musician's musician so that's where like
the fact that you know I could play
drums piano guitar all of that stuff
I've never really been like oh look how
well I rhymed these words together shout
out to everybody who does that but that
was never like my main focus because I
was more about creating movements and
creating opportunities so uh I'm glad
now that I get the opportunity to kind
of take that side of my career seriously
when you have like someone like her you
sign her as a kid sign her as a kid
um or Kaylani was she signed you before
she was 18 yeah yeah they were she was
right before she finished high school
what was the name of the group that went
on tour with tech nine like uh psych
ward druggies a kid passed away who was
in there yeah Ryan Bowers rest his soul
man that was my man
but do you like like you let them out of
their deals did the deals run their
course I'm not even one of them dudes
like I'm like everybody else around me
wants me to be one of those dudes like
take the credit and sign on me you need
your logo on it I'm like look give me
the credit when you want to give me the
credit like other than that it's cool
like I'm a handshake type of person I
don't want nothing from you uh except to
see you win so that's a rare thing in
this game but it's like I always tell
artists that I rock with look I'm Gonna
Be Rich whether you make it or not like
so I don't need like those ideas is like
I don't need anything from you like I'm
just gonna help you out so all I want to
let me help you I'll give you advice and
see how you run but you know obviously a
lot of people think that you know I
should I should be taking percentages
and doing all of that so usually I only
ask for you know ass back for the money
that I put in if you're if you're stable
enough to do that but I don't even have
I mean you know these major labels still
owe me owe me checks for you know the
artist that I kindly just gave them so
but I just I did that because I wanted
to see those artists win and didn't want
them to get into a deal in debt so I can
always step away but you know those
those big record execs you know you know
who you owe
they owe you some money absolutely for
for yes for her and Kayla I mean if if
they look up the paperwork but I mean
I'm good with all those people just
based off of the but I definitely like I
said I never wanted anything from them
right like I always wanted them to
succeed in even their Arrangements that
we made with uh various management and
various uh record labels I was like yo
I'll be I'll step back now that I know
they're in good hands you know I'm off
to the next thing because I really don't
want anything from anybody but when
those major systems who make hundreds of
millions of dollars off of these artists
like yeah here let me get my investment
back yeah yeah yeah at least give me the
money that I've spent to to bring them
to you so you know but again I ain't
that that small paper I ain't really
counted was there anyone who uh you
almost signed that it got right to the
finish line but for whatever reason yeah
a couple of people like Becky G I
remember Becky G early on you know uh
she was she was like a little 14 year
girl rapping yeah uh
uh so many people uh
I mean because I used to run uh teen
Island at Def Jam LA Reid put me in
charge of all of the team acts and you
know obviously the the it was it was a
cool roster it was a group I created
called the school girls this artist
named Aaron Fresh who was super dope uh
and we had a arsenal of artists and I
was making I was putting them all in
Gabby was a part of that as well we put
them all in these Nickelodeon movies uh
that we were making in the first the the
star at the time the one that obviously
the the biggest act on teen Island he
just was bubbling up the internet was
this young kid named Justin Bieber
the rest is history really the whole
teen Island budget just folded and went
into beaver's career and it's the Justin
Bieber that we know to to this day so
was that prior to him linking with Usher
it was during the same time same time
same time that's what like it was like I
said Tina he had he got the deal in the
building but as you you know you know
they upstreamed him quickly yeah yeah so
like uh I think think the the
Nickelodeon movie that we put on was
Justin's first thing ever on television
so uh in the first movie and stuff that
he had ever did because before then he
was just this dope little kid from
YouTube that they were about to put out
a record and all that and so I was like
yo he bout to go and then he he went oh
he went oh yeah
um can you give for people who are
watching this who want to get involved
in making original content or maybe they
want to try to figure out how to get an
idea they have for a TV show going or
something like that but maybe they not
might not necessarily have the
relationships the resources whatever it
is what would be some advice you would
give them don't stop I mean to
think about like everybody can do all of
this literally from their phone uh
that's even one of the reasons why I'm
excited about launching a daily Cannon
because it's like it's literally from
your phone if need be like the fact you
can make millions of dollars from your
phone so there's no more excuses back in
the day I used to have to shoot pilots
and rent cameras and spray all of that
stuff to to just to get my ideas out now
you can do the same level of content
from your phone like if like if you
listen to DC Young Fly story man he was
young like he didn't even have a phone
he had to steal somebody's phone and
maybe the content to you know now do is
a millionaire in a household name so
it's like there are no excuses you could
do it from the trap you could do it from
your projects you could do you know the
Homie watomi Quan he's like dude I do
everything on my phone everything you
see is edited on my iPhone these are the
two apps I use there's no exceptions you
know that was somebody you know I saw
his movement we gave him opportunity on
Wildland out so I was like there's no
excuses out there uh talk about the new
radio show Daily Cannon man it's a new
platform it's on AMP yeah yeah yeah so
which is owned by Amazon it's owned by
Amazon so we we over there cooking uh
but it's like it's beauty is Reinventing
radio and kind of bringing social media
and podcasting all into the same form so
it's it's dope because in the same way
like I'm always I remember when Twitter
first popped on I remember when Tick
Tock was musically I was in there and
like I feel like I feel like the same
Buzz uh is going on now with with uh
these ideas of like community and we've
seen it pop with Clubhouse but I feel
like amp is even taken to another level
because now you're allowed to have your
own show in your own content right and
your own brand right and they're
empowering you like through the system
of Amazon so you know it's no more
talking at people it's talking with
people so everybody can have a show
everybody can have listeners so that's
how we rocking you know Monday through
Friday 6 a.m to 9 A.M so you're doing
that Monday through Friday six to nine
live live
what the [__] and this is with Abby yeah
yeah she's gonna be on there too so
shout out to Abby DJ Abby De la Rosa she
playing music yeah oh so she's playing
music you're hosting yeah yeah she's
part of the show too but you gotta have
her talk with that voice yeah yeah now
she's up but she she runs she's the
musical director as well so she's she's
getting it in yeah shout out to Abby for
people who don't know your uh two two of
your kids oh she had twins yeah yeah
yeah she she been on radio for a long
time yeah started with young Cowboys she
was a star before before the candy yeah
it's not like you were like yo let me
put my baby mama yeah she she's a master
in this space if anything I need her
more than she needs me in this space so
that's six to nine wilding out then the
new show with Kevin Hart where you're
you're pretty much it's kind of like
filling a space that has been vacated
for a very long time because back in the
day we had punked yeah before that
Candid Camera uh celebrity bloopers and
practical jokes and all that stuff but
now we just did it you know everybody
know was me and Kevin like ever since we
got money we started playing pranks on
each other right uh and you know that's
what rich friends do to each other so we
wanted to be like yo we could we should
turn this into a TV show and let the
world in on it because I mean we were
doing it through social media already
but now it's a number one show on E yo
you mentioned you being rich you have
all the money uh you don't leave no
money for nobody else
now I'm at the stage in my life where
I'm trying to get everybody else it's
it's Lonely at the Top baby like I want
my friends to be rich too so that's
always been the concept so now I'm at
the stage it ain't I don't care about
making money no more I want some
Financial friends and family financial
literacy advice from Nick Cannon yes
give me give me a few gems listen I've
had lots of babies and instead of giving
them the money create trust in their
name so by the time they're 18 year old
they're CEOs of their own company and it
could be whatever the company they want
to be and you finance it so now you
birthed the business and also isn't
there some sort of like account that you
can put a certain amount of money in for
each kid it's a tax write-off every year
well that don't [__] with the IRS we
ain't trying to get no tax write-offs I
give all my money to where it's supposed
to be you pay taxes yeah absolutely but
you're too rich to be paying no but see
what it is you got to understand you
gotta have your tax money make money but
we'll get into that in another
conversation but I'll give the
government everything they ask for your
tax money make money yes so you you
again I give the government everything
they ask for I just really I get audited
like Nick I'm sorry listen Nick I'm
starting to do pretty good right now so
yeah I really just need some advice not
to be I mean honestly that that's don't
ever play with the IRS oh I'm not trying
to do it that's the best guy loopholes
yeah no [__] that okay because that's
where they go you see the the biggest
gangsters in the world what they're in
prison for tax evasion exactly so shout
out to Wesley sniper do not play like
give them the money that they asked for
but learn how to how to get your money
and operate and give them everything
that they need but there's ways to
actually if you're a wise businessman if
you got good business man there's like
there's stuff in the tax code you can
take advantage of yeah but see like I
may I know not to get it to like I make
so much money that like all of that that
concept of oh or tax write-offs that's
only for when you when you're in a
certain level when you make more when
you pay more in taxes than most people
make in a lifetime I just you always
hear how like Jeff Bezos doesn't pay
taxes stuff but that's what I see that
yeah that's not what they so what
they're saying is there's infrastructure
set up I'll give you a part example like
um and that's just it was probably gonna
get a little too deep but when you get
into like the world of like lobbyists
and in the world of like even
non-profits in that sense to where
there's levels you can give an abundant
amount of money to things that you
really care about and it and and you
would rather do that than give it to the
IRS yeah or and that's legal yeah it's
you can give you can you can have uh
charitable for philanthropic efforts
where you can give hundreds of millions
of dollars away to education to child
care to uh and you would rather do that
than give it to you yeah because and and
you're saying that's not illegal you're
saying hey government let me do what
you're doing right you know what I mean
it looks like you would rather spend
your tax money on stuff that you care
about
exactly so what lobbyists is Nick
Cannonball what are we lobbying for Nick
well let's see that's where you know I
feel like nobody knows where you are on
the political Spectrum
a political yeah that's how it should be
you're Nick Cannon you're like an enigma
yeah I was like you know I'll let them
live how they want to live
um yo did you ever regret bringing all
the Wild and Out Boys into your beef
with Eminem No I thought that was
amazing you
your attention is my currency baby keep
keep it going all of those guys are a
lot more popular now and than they were
before they started it and that was I
mean that was all again that was all the
media that was just trying to get people
to watch wilding out you shot a music
video for that oh we shot several yeah
Kevin we were on the set a while and out
but the logos was all in the back do you
think MGK beat Eminem in their battle
what what it depends on beat I think I
think he won
yeah I think I won
don't agree with oh I don't I don't
agree if somebody picks a fight but
doesn't show up to the fight
I don't think he would
so so who won how did he win by not
responding he did respond first of all I
responded to him he started talking [__]
first he was on fat Joe's record Talking
how many years ago see but that's the
thing everybody think I don't I love
okay stop
and then wear it off like a little [__]
so you think because Eminem didn't reply
to your records he did not no he started
he started making records about what he
said on the Fat Joe record he did like I
don't know something like a lot of [__]
and I was like I went on I was like why
are you [__] with me like I don't I
know like foreign
like that was years ago so then you
reply so I was like oh let's have some
fun and I had a great [__] time he
got sugar on the record it was it was
lit I don't [__] had on a song is
this from jail yeah
just called in like [__] back in the
day when uh who was that rapper from
Sacramento x-rated you never X-rated
now but I I think it was all for sport I
mean I love him I mean I love I mean
even so you think you won the battle
absolutely like if we're talking for the
sport he didn't respond
I don't think he needed to he started
see you wanted you're under the mother
Mountain Dew [__] on Twitter
I never know this guy I did first of all
I didn't I would love it if I mean he he
responded with a tweet and I was like
because that became the narrative
because if you remember how the
narrative I smashed him over the head
people like oh [__] this [__] is hot
then I gotta look no absolutely I
smashed him over the head then I came
again and they were like that's when I
brought you know the black Squad and all
the battle rappers and I'm like I just a
little too much they're beating their
now you guys are bullying him that was
the thing and then and then when I did
no that's what they said they said we
were bullying him he's like it's three
on one you had to go get battle rap
that's what I said yeah yeah see then
the third time I started bringing race
into it now that's why I went too far
then it just looked like I I was I did
too much I should have stopped at the
second record you should have put
Benzino on a song hey that was next
Everlast just pull it all his [__]
but we all know Eminem is the goat and
like he's one of them yeah he can uh
yeah he's definitely you know top five
top five yeah but I think Drake is
coming for a spot though like that's
that's I mean there's an argument made
drinks because it's All About Numbers
Drake might have passed Eminem
so then M might not have that fifth spot
Eminem's a better rapper though
what is what is your definition of
better
I mean Eminem is a better word Smith
lyrics he's better oh I don't know about
Lyricist well I mean we've definitely
we've heard slower and Storyteller we
have heard Drake reference tracks
but see I don't want to get into that
because Drake is a better song maker
than the majority of the industry one
million percent Drake will wipe his ass
with Eminem as a song maker but if we're
talking about bar for bar
punchline and lyricism imma go with
Drake word play
even because only thing about because
WordPress because wordplay has to do
with flow and Eminem is the king of flow
you think Drake bar for bar is better
than Eminem
um yeah well we'll see that like
strictly if you're because lyric like
Eminem's a great Storyteller might be
one of my favorite storytellers in
hip-hop and that's I got him Cube biggie
Slick Rick storytelling and that to me
is probably the most difficult part of
hip-hop for sure uh pocket as well you
know Brenda's Got a Baby keep your head
off yeah
oh see I don't hope is a great story he
has a song called Meet the Parents it's
on the blueprint too it's one of the
best storytelled records ever oh no I
mean just Streets is Watching and that
whole project but if we're going the
guys who can tell a [__] story Eminem
is probably number one because ain't
nobody topping Stan ain't nobody topping
rewind
he's good but he's not consistent with
this story it's not like assistant with
lyricism now but Nas did a whole story
backwards backwards I mean Nas did a
whole record as a bullet like like
creativity is out of here but if we're
talking storytellers Eminem is a better
Storyteller than Drake but if we're
going oh that bar for bar Eminem's never
said nothing bar wise that blew my mind
what is he said like Hey listen I'm just
letting you talk mom spaghetti
spoken from a man who lost a battle
[__] you Cam
I did not lose and I said you might not
have lost but you didn't win yeah well I
showed up to the fight [__] you
didn't show up like but and that's like
you know I was just in Detroit last week
with my man Royce so that's it's off no
I mean listen that's that's great but I
think if we're talking about the sport
of it like to me hip-hop is wrestling I
think MGK won his battle because I think
the fact we even questioned it yeah
since he won I again I think he had a
better song yes and I think like he was
actually saying [__] that people were
like kind of thinking like yeah this guy
just wears [__] stupid sweatpants
he's been wearing the same Jordan
jumpsuit for 25 years but I think I
think
um
MGK made the same mistake that I made
that we were probably a little too
excited and too overzealous that we got
to battle with the leaned into it yeah
we got to get in the ring with one of
the best to ever do it right I'm dying
off I was excited oh [__] he's paying
attention let's go but we gonna get so
many while it out like because the whole
goal was to get attention right I mean
that's why everyone's on social media
don't give it [__] up you all sold
your souls
you got a [__] Instagram account
sold your soul to the devil Instagram uh
but so we were and the real goal I mean
it was conversations that were being had
behind the scenes like we was trying to
get them at least to even just give just
to step foot on one just a little in one
of your minions send Royce no but that's
one first of all Royce is a goat by
himself one of the greatest leaders hey
there's an argument to me lyrically
Royce is just as good as Eminem I'm just
saying if not better damn it I said it
like like but uh and I mean I'm pretty
sure em would say the same thing that's
the reason why he invested in them and
made him his partner put his arm around
him but uh it's just you know it is what
it is like dude we know what it is we
know these marketing machines are are
massive yo you're kind of like
Switzerland in so many ways I feel like
you're cool with so many people have you
tried to ever like bring people together
that are having disagreements yeah all
the time but the best in the game to do
that is fat Joe fat Joe's the one that
got me and him to to I mean he wasn't
beefing but Fat Joe was like because one
it started over his record and then uh
and then he was like man come on y'all
was that on the Lean Back Remix
it was Joe's last album oh
yeah Eminem has a song that's what
started all this [__] I was on the
station at Power and people like you
heard Eminem dissing I was like you mean
20 years ago there's like no today
Lord above I think I heard it one time
he brought up awesome oh [__] damn
Eminem can't let go man I want do you
think he's just sitting at home watching
while I'm out like [__] this 20 Seasons
[__] this guy nah nah at this at this
point I think you know because what was
it all over Mariah right I get that's
where he started talking [__] and then
that's where you know again I always
never ever knew what the [__] actually
because he would bring up Mariah so much
in raps I was like that was like what
the [__] like yeah I think it's it's a
little bizarre yeah you know he's a
bizarre yeah
bizarre from D12 yeah yeah
uh they gonna be coming at you [__] you
Kev that's why your bootleg
they're going to be someone dissed me
that's what they'd say that's exactly
that's those guys on Twitter
I see the comments all the time now I
know I call you [__] blackheads you
don't come up with nothing original who
you got in a lotto Nicki battle
if you ask me Kim or Nikki I'm gonna go
Kim
really she didn't write her [__] Yeah
well yeah
only reason I say I'm talking about the
hierarchy Queen Nikki's I think Nikki is
the female goat she is I think first of
all that's not disrespecting Nikki is a
goat whether whatever her gender no no
for sure she's one of the coldest
artists in the last decade 100 like we
can't sleep on the like her skill her
pin sonically she changed she's washed
the goats on their on records that's
what she like exactly when she came with
that monster yeah that was her record
yeah and she that was whole Kanye raw
slay she is whatever gender aside sex
aside she is she's that [__] dope she's
that only person in that that she could
to me that has the same level of talent
and that you should even we should even
be comparing her to is Lauren I was
gonna say Lauren
those three that's those that's those
see I kind of Mount right I agree Missy
to me probably out of the three we just
named as my favorite music
well there was the score and then the
miseducation but I just feel like Missy
had like a four or five album run that
was just like Jesus Christ but those
those are the three she was working with
Timberland yeah dope Missy helping right
for [__] genuine oh everybody Aaliyah
everybody SWV Missy's Missy's
but so Missy Nikki as well as Lauren
who's your overall top five all time and
no order I don't make you put that's so
difficult I mean we do this on my show
all the time we break it down in
categories that's why I was talking like
Storyteller but if we're just saying
overall overall
okay there's like just the most
influential person in hip-hop to ever do
it okay um Ben Hove the best to ever do
it to from the authenticity I agree like
I said we went from influence uh then we
went to uh then it gets tricky because
there's so many other people that could
check this box right but I need like
like more the the effect on the culture
with your lyricism
ah
that's when you got to give it to the
ogs so that's where you got to go into
space is like the the the the rock hymns
the ll's the ice cubes like that's I I
if I they're equal to me but if I'm
gonna have to go most successful I'm
gonna go Cube I'll say you gotta say
cute yeah yeah so cute so I go Cube S3
uh and then
[__] that's where we get to that sticky
Point uh well you already said Eminem's
top five but that's what I'm saying what
I'm saying because I'm still I'm gonna
give you my last three and this is six
okay so give me six so it has to be
between
Kendrick Drake and M I love that you put
Kendrick in there it has to I agree with
you man yeah like it got so but I don't
know where those three go that's fair I
like can like Drake might cancel out
right him and put him at six Kendrick
might cancel out Drake and put him at
like I don't know where those last three
go like well really because there's only
two spots left and I got three people I
love the uh that's a good six yeah yeah
so it's a respectable six yeah yeah only
person missing is Nas in my opinion
cube out
I would what cube is done for the
culture though uh
the at that level though okay what about
this there's this debate
50 Cent versus Lil Wayne in a versus
Battle who wins all day I agree because
this Wayne got more records yeah 50 has
the biggest song in hip-hop history
let's not get it in the club is the
biggest song it's either that or Usher
yeah which is not necessarily hip hop
the two biggest songs in hip-hop history
are Rappers Delight in the club yeah my
kids know both of those for sure you
know what I mean like and it's just like
that I feel like 20 years from now we'll
be saying the same thing the two biggest
dogs if uh are rappers are Lighting in
the club because that's just they're
bigger than they're damn near bigger
than hip-hop
hey we gotta stop the interview shout
out to our our great sponsors at hardean
Las Vegas you see them they gave me this
amazing box to keep
my things in what kind of things
premium things that you can buy at
hardean Las Vegas yeah if you're in
Vegas stop off at hard Dean tell them I
sent you they'll take care of you all
right number one dispensary I've ever
been into the nicest dispensary in the
world they got their own [__] scent
they got the biggest craziest selection
of Premium cannabis you will ever see in
your life you walk in and you feel like
they just treat you like family as soon
as you walk in all right so look this is
what you're gonna do you're gonna go to
hardinglasvegas.com check them out go
follow them online Harding underscore
Las Vegas and when you're in Las Vegas
this is your first stop
you don't go to the [__] Casino you
don't go to the you go to [__]
Jardine get situated say bootleg have
sent me I heard about him on the bootle
cat podcast they're gonna take care of
you they'll throw a little a little
extra on it on the extra you know what I
mean go follow them Harding underscore
Las Vegas and of course you can also
follow them right now by going to their
website check out what they got going on
man they got the gear for sale they just
dropped their own pair of Filas
hardinglasvegas.com gotta give a shout
out to our oh geez my dogs at Odd Socks
baby they've been [__] with us from
day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butthead socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and butt head draw skis bro
oh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
otsoxofficial.com my first uh suggestion
would be get you a pair or a pack of the
Odd Socks Basics the black and the
whites those are my go-to's and then you
gotta [__] with some of these Big
Lebowski socks
and they just got Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bruh what are we talking about
go to oddsoxofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview did you and little Rob
ever link on some like Transformers of
SD area like super like nah I mean they
they go is a weird City too because it's
a
it's a lot of it's a lot of tension
right and you went between the two
communities just not not but it's like
even you know like you know my I got you
know half of my family is Latino and
stuff too so even it's always been love
and respect and that nature but I think
because people don't give San Diego the
respect that it deserves so the culture
is constantly trying to prove itself to
itself almost like prove itself to La a
little right that's what I'm saying even
more like trying to be like yo we gonna
We I'm gonna put this I want to be the
one to put it on so it's a lot of people
trying to tear each other down that
makes sense because I think SD I think a
you Mitchy Slick jail felony and Rob
Stone Rob Stone and little Rob yeah yeah
jail felony was semester absolutely yeah
bully Loco shout out to jail yeah that's
the home there it is man well look the
show is
um
daily Cannon it's gonna be happy because
I know this [__] going viral you don't
have me say all type of wild [__] that
so uh you got the new TV show level of
conversation we got Prank Wars which is
on yeah yeah wilding out new season is
Aaron that's I go against myself in my
own time slot you're going great Wars
and Wildlife
two different companies
that's it that's NBC you've got that in
your contract because I'm me [__] about
all y'all I'm him no I'm me it's a
difference you can be him I'm me
there's only one me last one uh who you
voting for Joe Biden or Donald Trump
Donald Trump let's go you're voting for
Trump I only vote for no I don't believe
in this corrupt government system but I
[__] with Trump I like how I like how
Trump tell everybody kiss his ass so
you're gonna go with Trump if it's
between the old fogy and uh the old
red-haired boy the only thing is because
Trump I like my racism served right to
my face I I've heard a lot of people say
that I don't like people lying to me and
then fronting it's it's almost like
you'd rather have someone tell you what
they're gonna do about someone square up
than to punch me in the back of my head
um simple as that cause now I got a fair
fight all right but don't don't act like
you [__] with me and then throw some
[__] at me like like that so the thing
about Trump I know what I know to feel I
know what I'm playing with but let's
keep it all like W.E.B the boy said this
there's no such thing as two parties
just one party with uh two names one
evil party 100 is what uh W.E.B the boy
said hey you are somebody yeah who could
literally be the president of the United
States that people are saying I've been
trying to [__] up on purpose so they
don't I'm telling you you could be the
[__] president bro I don't want it
but one day you could be the pre you
could be the governor
you could be the governor of California
Senator you could bro you're I don't
want that job but I people have told me
that all my life but like because but
it's politics but if you felt like you
got to lie to people for a living I
don't know you might be able to like be
the guy who doesn't lie to people that I
think that's what Trump tried to do and
everybody turned on them and now I'm
gonna [__] might go to jail
you might like that's the thing like I
did too much dirt that I have to like I
mean but you ain't doing I read this
feeling I'd rather spend all my money in
like uh on children and in other
countries and building like I can
probably do just as much good in the
world with just philanthropy and
humanitarianism than I could if I
because because it was thinking about it
politics and especially the presidential
campaign is all about ego right it's not
about like like it's about like about
power and it's likable but even to this
is like Who Wants To Rule I don't want
that job I want to be in charge of War I
want to be in charge of killing people
like as much like I love Barack Obama
but I guarantee he's like yo if I would
have known I had to make some of the
decisions he has a hard time sleeping
tonight because I mean he was letting
them drones fly right [__] Barack had
them drones leave it like we ain't gonna
talk about some of the [__] that
happened in Africa I'm like whoa that
way hold on but we ain't gonna get into
that we're going too deep anyway but to
say I don't want them I don't want none
of them problems so I'd rather spend all
my money help World I'd rather let's do
it in your way let's name some hospitals
after me let's let's name some Library
I'll buy all of that [__] I do not want
to be in the game of politics yo I want
to see you going to Joe Rogan show I'm
love that's my man I haven't done Joe
Rogan's show but I mean we know each
other
Joe [__] with your boy or have Joe come
on my show
bring the [__] podcast back yeah it
was so good bring the same table back
all of that's coming bro I got you dude
we on the same page in the cannon I
appreciate you better all day love
appreciate you all right let's go